hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde in meinem letzten videos martin
a tor habe ich euch als hausaufgabe
aufgegeben dass sie doch bitte mein bild
auf dieser website ändern mögt denn das
alte war ziemlich hässlich
und eigentlich besteht auch kein
verbesserungspotenzialen allerdings
wirklich sagen schauen wir doch einfach
mal nach also erste frage ist eine figur
weiblich ja/nein leb deine figuren
deutschland ja ich bin noch nicht nach
portugal gegangen macht eine figur
minecraft videos vor
frühjahr
jetzt nicht mehr alles klar
wir haben zeit
wurde deine figur durch youtube berühmt
ja das stimmt trägt deine figur ein bad
also das ist ein klares jahr definitiv
also der vollbart ist auf jeden fall
darum blogs spiele ich nicht lieber
akinator ist deine figur im sportclub
das ist im sportklettern das habe ich
nie verstanden die leute einfach so
geklettert sind
so braun doch die treppe oder den
fahrstuhl nein selbstverständlich bin
ich nicht im sportklettern tätig spielt
die figur gerne fort nadelöhr bin
ziemlich schlecht ist eine figur ein
gamer will ich jetzt auch eher nein
sagen spielt da eine figur schon mit
campino
hat deine figur etwas mit musik zu tun
also ich hab halt kollege aber ich
glaube das ist jetzt nicht gemeint
sondern würde ich auch hier eher sagen
nein hat deine figur zwei kindern ich
hab 17 ist denn die figur kugelförmig
bloß geht um mich und nicht um sandra
ist deine figur ein deutscher letzten
jahr
ordnen will mich im let's play segment
ein oder er hat eine figur bei eine
million abonnenten ja das stimmt hat
deine figur 10
der eilig
schon wieder abbricht
dann ist holland in not hat der name
deiner figur vier buchstaben jahr lukat
vier buchstaben
[Musik]
heißt der sor dahin war ja der name ist
konkret da dann weiß ich warum ich dann
jetzt kennt man deine figur von galileo
nee also ich glaube ich war damals zu
sehen aber ich glaube man kennt mich
nicht von da mag deine figur
körperkontakt also madison wenn du das
sehen sollte an deine figur springen
er ist eine figur ein innenverteidiger
also ich hab halt früher fußball
gespielt aber da war ich
außenverteidiger so maßmann
von daher sage ich auch hier nein sagt
deine figur bei youtube am anfang hallo
mein name ist luca in letzter zeit
irgendwie nicht mehr einige kommentare
gesehen dass leute das vermissen
allerdings ja
liga
du weißt dass der name der figur call
crafter ist und dass sie am anfang hallo
mein name ist luca sagt warum bist du
noch nicht auf ihn gekommen
nossek schuld macht eine figur let's
play sbo ich sage jetzt einfach ja damit
er das so
ihr seid zu nichts
auch wirklich gar nicht zu gebrauchen
ich wurde zuletzt vor vier minuten
gespielt das ist toll aber niemand hat
mein neues bild eingereicht
leute jetzt bitte alle mal einen
screenshot machen
und das reichte da jetzt ein
uns gibt's diesmal doppelt so viele
hausaufgaben dass ich euch ebenfalls als
hausaufgabe aufgegeben habe es dass sie
diese schnecke
ebenfalls beim akinator mal einreicht
hat deine fresse bastard dankeschön von
einer netten worte
ich mache jetzt mal einfach tier ist ein
tier klein ich würde sagen ja
der hund ist ein tier ein haustier nähe
würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen hatte
und ihr fell
ist ein tier ein insekt u
ich glaub ja
ich glaube schnecken das drop oder
griechisch verbrauch von althochdeutsche
hahn griechen sind eine tier klasse aus
dem stamm der weichtiere daran gewöhnen
dinge zutragen
ja klar also trägt hat ihr häuschen kann
nennt hier fliegen auf gar keinen fall
kann nennt ihr menschen verletzen auch
nicht hat und ihr beide lebt ein tier
unterirdisch würde ich auch nicht sagen
hat denn hier weißes fällen ein krieg
denn hier ja ja ja ja ja
schon gesagt jetzt hat ein tier eine
schale panzer ja hat es auf jeden fall
es hat eine schale also ein häuschen
dass das ding häuschen als er ist
einfach seine kacken muschel
der jetzt mach alt war hat sich dein
tier unsichtbar machen
kein tier kann sich unsichtbar machen
nein natürlich nicht kann man ein tier
und asche aufbewahren kann man den
tieren tasche auf beworben ja
macht ein tier mehr gemacht hat und hier
fühle
schnecken haben ja diese dings hier ne
so und fahren die sich eigentlich ein
aber bei dir nicht weil du bist ein
kleinem ist ja mein tier hat fühler ist
denn hier für kinder geeignet egal
also ich als kind hab immer mit so
schnecken rom gespielt aber ich weiß
nicht ob das damit gemeint ist ich
glaube die man eher so meerschweinchen
lebt ein tier im dschungel nähe auf gar
keinen fall
lebt ein tier aufbäumen würde ich jetzt
auch eher sagen nein ist denn hier
schleimig ja
[Musik]
wenn man mit deinem tier kuscheln alter
auf gar keinen fall ist denn hier pferde
art ich nie einig brutto was meint ihr
schleimig ist ein panzer hat und kriecht
also mehr hat kann er nicht jetzt von
mir wenn hier kann man auch nicht am
strand finden es hat keine große
schnauze und jaja die stärke wurde
weinbergschnecke ja es ist die
weinbergschnecke sie wurde zuletzt
gespielt heute vor eineinhalb stunden
welcher mensch denkt sich an einem
sonntagmittag haye
jetzt suche ich meine beine
schnecke bei akinator an der stelle
durch das heutige video ist allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch mal wieder akinator mit mir
einer weinbergschnecke wenn euch das
heutige video gefallen hat das gerne
einen daumen hoch und ein video
abonniert main kanal falls die
zukünftige videos nicht verpassen wollt
und
ganz ganz wichtig schreibt namen für
diese schnecke und in die kommentare
ich habe mir ein überlegt
der ist aber glaube ich nicht so cool
stefanie schneck
wir machen müssen meine lieben freunde
auf jeden fall mein neues bild bei
akinator einreichen und unseren podcast
folge hören sie ist gar nicht so neu es
kommen ja immer neue podcast folgen am
donnerstag um 9 uhr aus von sander und
mir auf spotify falls das überhaupt noch
gar nicht wissen wir haben podcast dick
und doof da geht es um ganz viel politik
wirtschaft aktien und eigentlich um gar
nichts von dem was ich gerade gesagt
habe sondern primär nur um
[Musik]